هذه سيارة فورد شيلبي جي تي 500 الجديدة ، لديها
قوة 760 حصان بقوة 760 حصان ، ولديها مكابح ضخمة
يمكنها أن تصل من صفر إلى 60 في ثلاث
ثوان ونصف ، لكن هذا هو العالم الحقيقي
وليس شريط سحب ، والأمر الأكثر
إثارة للدهشة هو أنه بخير.
هنا
واحدة من تلك الأشياء المثيرة للإعجاب حول
GT500 هي أنها تقود بشكل عادي على
الطرق العامة ، يبدو الأمر وكأنني فورد موستانج ،
لا أشعر أنني أقود السيارة إلى 7 سيارات أقل
من 60 حصانًا ، وهذا أمر
مروع للغاية للقيادة معظم الوقت حتى
لقد وصلت إلى مسار ، إنه في الواقع جيد للغاية
فواتير عادية رمادية
على عكس الإصدارات السابقة من gt500 ،
تشعر هذه السيارة بالتوازن والثقة
ليس فقط أنها سريعة الزوايا تقريبًا
كما أنها تسرع لا يمكنك الحصول على
ناقل حركة يدوي ولكن هذا
جيد في التكنولوجيا الفائقة
يعمل ناقل الحركة الأوتوماتيكي بـ 7 سرعات بشكل رائع وأنا أكره
كسرها لك ، ربما تكون معدات السفن
أفضل وأسرع منك ،
كل هذه القوة تأتي بسعر يعتبر
PT 500 أسوأ اقتصاد في استهلاك الوقود من
f-150 أسوأ بكثير
[  موسيقى]
لا تزال هذه السيارة رائعة من حيث
اتساع قدراتها ، حيث يمكنك
إسقاط طفلك بسهولة في المدرسة
والتوجه إلى دراغستر بلمسة من
بضعة أزرار كانت تتسابق ربع ميل
في 11 ثانية مع أداء مثل
هذا Shelby GT500 70000 دولار  يبدو أن السعر ليس
سيئًا على الإطلاق
بالنسبة لهذا النوع من القدرة الحصانية
والسرعة عادةً ما ينظرون إلى السيارات الخارقة من
إيطاليا وليست سيارات المهر من ميشيغان
[موسيقى]